[Applaudissements]
alors pour vous m'avez proposé maxime un
tour de magie je les lis c'est pas trop
mon truc et j'ai dit je vais réaliser
une expérience extra sensorielle alors
vous savez que depuis 25 ans je l'ait
déjà raconté dans l'émission j'ai volé
de la terre un jour pour faire une
expérience savoir si elles étaient
contaminés elle l'était j'ai inhalé de
la poussière
j'ai touché cette terre c'est donc
depuis j'ai dans mon organisme du
plutonium à césium 137 je suis
radioactifs
c'est à dire 15 janvier à les voir
j'entre en fusion moléculaire parfois
avec ses petits pas vous allez voir avec
les trois éléments
alors la terre il y en a pas ici dans le
studio le feu on a jugé maxime vous avez
décidé que c'était un peu dangereux
donc je vais vous réalisez une
expérience de fusion avec l'eau donc
j'ai demandé à la production d'objets
très simple qu'on m'a apporté de l'eau
de l'onho très bien ça va coûter très
cher nous a pas coûté très cher donc
voilà c'est de l'eau de la simple
o'kelly oui vous allez goûter et au
exactement vous allez 17 au goutte à
goutte et jurent qu'ils ont trouvé dans
che avec le tour de gérald non c'est
normal et c'est de l'eau normale c'est
de l'eau normale donc maintenant ses
taux va faire un avec mon corps d'accord
pour l'instant c'est le tour le plus
impressionnant je trouve voilà je vais
transcender les éléments je vous demande
simplement si lens a ce qu'il faut que
je me concentre
oui il faut une fusion énergétique je
vous demande simplement le silence le
plus complet et partir pendant le touche
on en restait là j'ai besoin de vous
vous allez me donner votre énergie
le silence est d'or
je suis prêt concentrez vous concentrez
vous même consentie oui j'avais fait un
visible avec l'eau je vais faire un avec
la fusion avec la fusion allait encore
non
m
[Applaudissements]
c'est un secteur de la chimie fine et
avait dégueulasse et derrière
franchement à deux derrière
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]